I think that because they're a part of
the elite ruling class that they're
exempt from the rules and that's
arguably worse they want to force
everybody else to live by these rules
and aren't willing to do it themselves
this is today the top five ideas
concepts philosophies top five things
that left to claim they believe they
don't actually believe we've been going
through this quit and it says this goes
far beyond hypocrisy but first off
everyone's hypocrite let me preface it
with this myself included but as you
look at the political landscape today
which side of the hell do you think is
more blind spots to hypocracy which one
better practice what they preach more
importantly do you think today that the
left even believes half of the things
that they say and I don't want a
question motive but it's at some point
when I go you don't believe there are
genders at all or open like completely
open borders I want to know what you
think genuinely if you could you could
let me know but there are quite a few
things that you can look at tangibly and
say okay the left espouses this huh but
they don't believe in it
I'm not saying they don't practice it
they clearly don't believe in it
interactions are not following what they
say well no but see that could just be
hypocrisy this is if the actions
actually if you look again you guys can
I mean it's a first one free speech
isn't absolute we here this one left all
the time right they love to hate on the
idea of free speech particularly in both
that First Amendment how often do they
use that example will they claim like -
they use the example of fire in a crowd
of deiicate you'll fire in a car theater
free speech is in absolute that's it but
they're the first to say the First
Amendment when conservatives don't like
what they say look at like Michelle wolf
with the White House Correspondents
there the comedian did her job she is
there to come and push the envelope
that's what comedians do at the end of
the day if this is a defense the First
Amendment then you back comedians right
but private group bringing somebody in
on a college however like the Young
Republicans bringing in perhaps yours
truly to an audience of thousands of
people that can't be allowed because
free speech is not absolute but the
White House Correspondents Dinner your
job is to push the envelope when you
have a right to say whatever you want at
the president of the United States and
you can suck it gets free speech yes
exactly because free speech number two
that fetuses aren't a life feet high
part of life this is one thing you
brother said how many times has the left
and how they've used pregnant and mom
others as a joke it's a trope to raise
the stakes of movie and every time I
watch a movie in there's a pregnant
mother at the very
I'm like yeah he's gonna die I think it
well Harbor or Harbor was one I can
think of him actually go ton of movies
yeah yeah they had the same trope that
you're like it's just foreshadowing
every single time because they pregnant
mother to raise the stakes yeah no
that's a good point
yeah look at in popular culture you look
at that children of men was one that
comes to mind where the the last portion
the last person born on earth was
literally a celebrity and I know The
Handmaid's Tale is they try to use it as
an example for pro-abortion
but being able if you think about it
really being able to birth a child is
such a valuable commodity any woman
who's there basically enslaved yeah I
never saw a good example Terminator 1
think of that say save the unborn John
Connor in the left they can't help
celebrating unborn babies in real life
this is why it's not just an autocracy
it's not just looking at the ethic on
the scripted content they slip up all
the time and this is where I'm not talk
about hypocrisy where someone says well
I believe will be better to give to
charity only I don't because people are
selfish they slip up when you can see
what they actually believe and they call
them babies or people instead of feet
it's all the time the most like picture
was at an instant most liked of 2017 all
yep all time Beyonce what was it
explaining for the audience
Beyonce her pregnancy announcement giant
hit was like the Instagram posts I think
of 2017 there you go the report about
why she was pregnant with a baby not a
fetus correct fend computer all the
tweets a baby bits know she has a second
baby our first baby you never called
that guy yes there's a pregnancy oh she
has a fetus love this life love to you
know say it's just just a futures clump
of cells but yet be mourn miscarriages I
could never understand I can every I'll
they put that together how do you mourn
simultaneously more and how do you
reconcile that yeah it's not it's not
alike and it's a feminist here miss care
she misses work for six months yeah by
the way the probe or some Clinton's they
certainly celebrated Chelsea's unborn
baby if you look at it and here's some
of it again it's it's the slip up it's
not just what they say and how they act
but when they don't know the cameras are
rolling or when their brain hasn't
registered because in the end their
dad's a pan pen yet when Hillary Clinton
slips up right here and even even refers
to the unborn child as a person the
unborn
person doesn't have constitutional right
nope definitely ten years I always
thought I heard zygote no no it was
really close
I have a cold he sound like zygotes
number three that less guns equals more
safety this is this is all the time and
I know this is one that's easy to point
you for it but we had to include it
right every single one from Jimmy Kimmel
to Bernie Sanders they all have
extensive armed protection here's the
thing it's not like what they have a
revolver and a pump shotgun they have
people with all of the guns that they
claim they want to be illegal one of my
favorite shows is the West Wing right so
the president actually gets shot and one
of those episodes in the very next thing
they say if you think more guns are the
solution to our problem the president
was surrounded by the best trained
people in the world and was still shot
and I was like and that's the only the
only reason that nobody else got shot
was because they took him down in seven
seconds yeah example with guns took down
the bad guy it's missing the boy that's
a good you know the perfect is the enemy
of the good
I think Voltaire said that um in in that
case we're not saying that if people
will you think you think that you can
outrun a nine-millimeter no we're not
saying that the president ever gets shot
but guess what at the end of the day
with every single one of those
apprehensions every single one without
exception it's a good guy with a gun
whether it's a civilian or trained
personnel it just increases the odds at
the end of all these stories the bad guy
were they're gonna stopped by somebody
with a gun even if you don't like him
because I think he's Blackwater ops all
right number four high taxes are Noble
or that at least they work this is
something that we hear a lot how many
Hollywood left us elite you use lawyers
to circumvent tax regulation they start
fake businesses they start nonprofits
offshore accounts to skimp on their fair
share of taxes one thing actually
finalized ethic nations I think was one
foundation from Bono ironically gave
less than 1% of total contributions to
of course you have rich Democrat
politicians they owe tons in backed out
listen this is this is too easy they
give almost nothing to charity and this
is one thing that is important there's a
book called who really cares though the
left they preach about giving a do poor
study after study after study after
study shows that they are consistently
less generous than conservatives and
again this isn't just about hypocrisy
personal with a few different people
like Joe Biden who I think gave less
than 2% to charity
this is about consistent empirical data
that shows the single biggest
determining factors and whether you are
charitable are are you conservative are
you a Christian or are at least
religious according to the studies that
I've read that's it and if you check no
to both of those boxes you're Bernie
Sanders and you're tipping 14 percent on
the dot not
yo [ __ ] all you did was pour the coffee
and it wasn't even a stainless steel
double walled carafe yo dad it was a
toddler I usually was Bernie Sanders by
the way of course just bought his third
house very beautiful not to be outdone
rabid anti-capitalist Michael Moore owns
nine houses which brings us to our next
one number five but that climate change
is lethal oh good good you can find your
pockets but I don't think they believe
this yeah and I don't want to be in the
business of questioning motives but I do
want to be in the business of observing
actions of observing behavior so how
many left us we did have multiple homes
multiple carbon emitting cars private
jets one of the big the guy who'd
narrated the polar bear film and also
wasn't wolf of wallstreet Leonardo
DiCaprio a world that we collectively
felt in 2015 as the hottest year in
recorded history our production needed
to move to the southern tip of this
planet just to be able to find snow
climate change is real it is happening
right now it is the most urgent threat
facing our entire species and and we
need to work collectively together all
right he bought his seventh house yes
here's something else that's really
interesting I didn't know reg told me
this our research to the beast this new
study shows it actually those highly
concerned about climate change they
actually typically make less
environmentally friendly decisions than
climate change skeptics what are they
like farming out the responsibility to
the governments they take care of it
that's not their own person they see the
government as the charity if again you
know either no prisons although
nonprofits they're the pre Redemption
Ebenezer Scrooge yeah Britain's poor
houses consistently yeah they should
take care of it and then post Redemption
Ebenezer Scrooge is all about his
personal charitable giving because he
knows that the government can't take
care of it right constant let's
constantly fight things that would help
their cause so birds scooters in Austin
was a great example we were there
recently
you're also know same thing with uber
the sharing economy solar panels in the
desert
Ted Kennedy didn't want wind turbines
because he didn't want to harm his view
the the bird scooters were we were
riding these all around Austin they're
fantastic they solve urban
transportation problem
solved the urban transportation problem
in where weather allows is largely
solved then our DiCaprio look at look at
the private jets of these celebrities
you see these are all you know here's a
good example right there are practical
decisions you could make the left
couldn't make they could shave off just
a little bit right instead of a private
instead of a Learjet use a PC 12 uses 27
percent of the fuel I've alluded I know
someone who's very wealthy in Texas huge
conservative could afford anything he
wants and guess what he uses he uses
that because it uses less fuel because
he realizes it doesn't want to waste
money and he shares it with other people
free market at work you know what lately
also appraisal you get your premier 45
minutes later if you buy the single
turbo problem I think I need nine
Learjets but but you can you need it you
need to use one roll of toilet paper
it goes beyond hypocrisy right everyone
everyone's a hypocrite I understand this
yours myself included it's a question of
genuine baseline sincerity and I can't
say that the motives are impure but
you're you if you actually believe that
my crossover is going to lead to this
just take the propeller plane-- get
their few nuts later that's all I'm
saying baby steps baby step into the
props I love babies to flying coach oh
hey if you like this video subscribe or
click the notification bell right next
to the subscription but because absque
riving doesn't mean anything anymore
now according to the YouTube gods and if
you like the late night show you can
watch it every single day a full hour at
loud with credit calm / mug Club
subscribe there that way we aren't
beholden to the evil YouTube overlords
and we don't have to start playing video
games with mouths sound effects or
children react